[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about plant
based on a budget we have Tony Okimoto
joining us on the show hello
ah thank you so much for coming on
really appreciate it I'm really excited
for this conversation
Tony Okamoto is the founder of plant
based on a budget which provides
delicious vegan recipes for under $30 a
week in less than 30 minutes a meal she
has taught hundreds of thousands of
people how to eat a plant strong diet
while saving money in the process going
vegan is not only an attainable goal but
the best choice for your health the
planet in your wallet and you can find
the book link in the bio as well as
plant based on a budget calm plant-based
meal plan calm and the Instagram plant
based on a budget and I love flipping
through this it is like making my mouth
water it's just super simple and it's
super affordable which is so critical
and I'm excited to unpack this with you
let's jump into things by asking you one
of our favorite questions what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
well I am really excited to so I live on
the internet a lot of my work is done on
the Internet and I see so many people
being active in different communities
some people are very passionate about
water access or sanitation systems
building sanitation systems in
developing countries and so to see
people really really active in their
communities trying to make the world a
better place makes me want to do the
same it's very inspiring and so I I
generally think that there are many
suffering people in the world and it is
our duty and our responsibility to ease
their suffering and so to see that
online and to see people who have an
influence on the Internet getting other
people inspired to do whatever they can
do whether it's big or small or make a
contribution financially is is inspiring
to me what an important synthesis yes
the access to the Internet and social
media and our ability to catalyze ideas
to spread and and hopefully eradicate
some of the suffering and issues that we
have and make life better across the
world and activate people and engage
them towards that yeah I'm glad that you
picked that as your as your direction of
our world I like that a lot yeah I've
really focused on this one issue of
plant-based eating for my whole adult
life and I recently started a podcast
with my husband Paul who it's called
business for good and we interview
people who are doing good in the world
with business and to hear what other
people are passionate about and how
they're solving these really big world
issues is just admirable to me I love
that people are using their platforms to
do good and using business to do good
and make a huge impact on the world whoa
okay and this is another interesting
thing to unpack with you is these guests
that you've had and you made me say that
for later oh yeah cuz that's that's also
so cool that you guys are doing that
okay let's get into the journey you
mentioned it in this last bit that you
started talking about this you spent
most of your adult life in the plan
based realm yep and how did you get
interested in that you spent most of
your life in the Sacramento California
area teach us about that okay so like
many people I grew up eating regular ol
standard American food I okay so I was
raised by my grandparents initially my
dad was in the Navy active duty and so
he went away it was in the war and was
gone until I was about eleven so in that
time I lived with my grandparents who
were fully retired and gave me all the
love and attention possible and one
thing that my grandpa was passionate
about was gardening and so he and my
grandma who cook from scratch all the
things that he made at home they
introduced me to delicious fresh food
but then when I went and heard with my
dad I didn't have a lot of that access
anymore and my dad didn't know how to
cook we ate a lot of chewy beans from
cans topped on top of a hotdog or like
frozen meals and Hamburger Helper and so
that's where my life was going and in
high school that's when it became a
little bit worse because I had access to
a lot fast food fast food was surrounded
by my my high school was surrounded by
fast food places and so a lunch I'd go
have food but I was also an athlete and
I would eat not good food a fast food
restaurant come to track practice and
not feel really great afterward and I
don't knock fast food because I think
that talked about for example has saved
me many times while traveling they have
clam paste options there but if you're
trying to optimize your health and
perform well as an athlete I would say
don't eat fast food before your before
your training so I eliminated the fast
food from my diet I stopped eating red
meat and that is the beginning of my
journey I was introduced to that from my
coach my coach was like hey Tony the
food that you put in your body is going
to affect how you feel and how you
perform and so I started eating a little
bit healthier and
that read me and so that was the
beginning
the genesis of my plant-based journey
was eliminating the red meat and you had
the grandparents to the dichotomy
between the grandparents gardening and
father that is doing frozen meals and
hotdogs and chili and stuff like that
toilet The Bachelor life yeah and this
is great because then you get to you get
to see both worlds and kind of start
forming the decision and also as an
athlete as well you get to realize that
that is the fuel that you're putting in
your body to be able to do things like
run track yeah so then what about you
know this Genesis okay why was it why
was it red meat as the thing they like
to cut he told me that that wasn't that
was not a healthy option for me and
again I didn't have any nutrition
information my coach was the first
person who helped me make the connection
between the food that we eat and the way
we feel and and so he said you know and
not in much detail he said you would
feel better if you stopped eating red
meat and you would it would be a healthy
decision so that was pretty much all he
told me and I felt the effects
immediately and so I stopped eating red
meat and after high school when I moved
out of my parents house it became a full
vegetarian and it was kind of out of
convenience and out of a little bit of
animal animal issues just a little bit I
I felt more comfortable learning about
it and I thought wow I had no idea but
then when I was in college so I went to
Community College - I went to Community
College and then I quit college and then
I went back later in life and finished
but a community college I went to a veg
Club they had a veg Club on campus and I
met people who are in a similar stage in
life as me who didn't have a lot of
money who had been deeply rooted in
their cultural foods who had many
obstacles to overcome to achieve a
plant-based diet and teaming up with
them made it a lot easier we
that a cook together we figured out how
to do it on a super cheap budget we
learned how to tell our parents because
if your parents want someone for example
want to feed me Mexican food and when I
go in and I'm like I don't want it I
can't eat your food anymore they're like
what do you mean you can't eat my food
anymore so there's a hole coming out my
parents they had a hard time with it and
it took years for them to start
accommodating me so it is a real
obstacle it's a struggle if you're in it
and you dine with your family a lot and
to me my family is super extremely
important and I love spending time with
them and sharing food is something that
we do to connect yes and to share love
and so I I that was it that was an issue
for me in the beginning but having other
people who were in a similar situation
and having that support system made it
an easier process yeah well you're
speaking to the support system when your
collegiate the veg club days and that
being so critical to to being able to
stay with what you're you know I spend
also doing things like analyzing you
were starting to analyze some of the
factory farming processes and as soon as
I became plant-based that world became
so much brighter and clearer to me that
I like the suffering was happening and I
wanted to make a change and if the
change the easiest thing I could do was
eliminate those products from my diet
and so I think it was because I let my
defensive neskowin because I was already
not eating animal products I I was able
to take in that information more does
that make sense yeah yeah
and this is it's it's a it's a cycle of
awareness expansion is really yeah the
key is that when we learn more about
where we come from in the cosmic
perspective and where we where we eat or
where our food comes from and just when
we tap into these things a little bit
deeper and double click into them we
usually at least become more aware of
the decisions that
making and what potentially consequences
some of these decisions have yes and
food choices are so personal and nobody
likes to feel like they are contributing
to suffering and so we justify all of
the behaviors that we do whether it's I
shop at places I know get the that has
poor quality of standards and so I know
that that's something I need to improve
but food choices that's something that
is so ingrained from the very beginning
of the what we learn from our parents
about food that the approach I take now
with plant-based on a budget is more
inclusive and it's meeting people where
they are because I face those same
struggles and I remember being so turned
off to the message when people were
demanding me to to be vegan or or and
best like you had to do it or nothing
and so that is such a turn-off message
to me yeah and I want to give people the
same experience and and freedom to make
their own choices as I had in my journey
yeah that's well said the way to
potentially argument people's awareness
and potentially change behavior is to
tell a powerful story and know something
that emotionally connects with people
where they're at and that yeah yeah and
so when when when we when we when I when
I hear you talking about this the
instances of like coming out to like
family like this is like you're like
young you're like zero to six months old
and you're already being fed things that
your parents think are good and then
tell your you know a teenager you're
still really you're not you don't have
money to go and buy your own groceries
so you're really just eating whatever is
at the house which is in itself your
some some serious subconscious
programming that's occurring through the
food that's in your home and the
decisions that are being made by your
family so then to be able to come and
say that hey like I have a veg club like
this is how I'm feeling right now I'm
doing my analysis that far maybe like I
don't want to like and they're kind of
like sometimes they have to give you a
little push back and they're like no you
have to eat meat or you have to eat what
we eat and so this is this can be hard
back and forth with with family and
friends you know kind of like a really
challenging part and I think that this
is for activism across the board is that
when you learn what's happening you want
to you want to spread that message and
you want everyone to adopt the lifestyle
that you've just chosen and so new
vegans or vegetarians they go home and
they're like did you know that animals
are dying and being killed by the
millions and billions and and and your
family they haven't learned all of that
yet they haven't researched it like you
have they don't have a support system
that you just built and so they're way
way step step steps behind you or maybe
not even on the same path as you right
now and so I think that just just offer
some grace and offers them like to put
things into perspective that they're
just not as advanced in that specific
choice that you've made is is going to
be the best decision yeah the on the
bell curve of adaptability towards the
ethics evolving it's
especially as we go like 50 years out
all the kids will be like what were you
doing slaughtering those animals so yeah
who you meet revolutions kicking off I
want to I want to know how did you make
the first firm from the veg Club and
from talking your parents and from
building up your community how long was
it until the super easy vegan slow
cooker cookbook Oh years these years
like ten to five ten how many years ah
probably I became vegan when I was 20
and I wrote that book when I was in my
late 20s yeah okay okay
in okay so tell us about like how did
how did it start the process of like
okay I'm making all this plant-based
vegan food like I want to share this
with people was that kind of the idea
it's a longer journey and it was very
slow for me as I mentioned I started
with the red meat and then I went to the
to being vegetarian and then a couple
years later I became plant-based but
that it's always been this slow and
steady progress for me yes where I
stopped drinking cow's milk and then I
stopped eating yogurt and like over time
let things go and that was a much easier
process for me personally I know people
who've done it overnight and they've
been successful but that was not me and
I really wanted this to last lifelong I
wanted it to be something that I can
hold on to forever and I needed to set
myself up for success and I went at a
pace that I felt comfortable with and
that I knew would set me up for success
and I'm really glad I did that because
it gave me a chance to find some
alternatives to change well on my palate
to change I didn't have a lot of
experience eating different or diverse
foods I had not tried the open I had
never tried Vietnamese I had never tried
all of these foods that I love now and I
had to change my palate to like those
tastes because I was a much pickier
eater when I ate everything which is
funny because a lot of people are like
I'm not gonna be able to eat anything
but for me I had
the opposite experience where it opened
me up to this whole world of new eating
and I am really grateful because I
remember one story in particular where I
went with my friend who was to begin to
a vegan restaurant it was a Vietnamese
vegan restaurant and he said I was in
high school so this was before I gave up
red meat but like before everything and
he said order anything
oh my treat I just want you to try the
vegan food and I ordered the white rice
like white steamed rice on the menu so
of all the things the only thing I would
try was the steamed white rice because I
I just was so intimidated by all the
vegan food that I had never heard it I'd
never had Vietnamese food before and and
so that's the kind of eater I was before
I became plant-based it was a so
definitely a journey for me and then I
want to go back really quickly to talk
about the activism part of my journey
because I was talking about how you you
don't want to force your opinions on
your family but something that I did
that I found really but that works is
sharing food right
sharing delicious food we went to an
animal sanctuary and pet animals and
learn about their stories and giving
them that connection that wasn't this
like showing them Meat Is Murder or
something where they're watching animals
being slaughtered it was instead giving
them insight into the lives that they
that they lead and and showing that
they're like their dogs or their cats
yep and and then there are some really
great documentaries on Netflix that are
not graphic so I would for my birthday
in lieu of gifts I would ask that we
have a vegan meal and we watch a movie
together and that has seemed to work too
so I don't think that people should
totally avoid talking to their families
because it can be helpful for them to
understand your lifestyle but I just
don't think we should be abrasive yeah
that's so well done is the
both the introduction of the movie and
meals like hey I made this beautiful you
know meal everyone free delicious food
and then and then also the new content
that's not yeah graphic can help but
then you you started giving us also this
trajectory you know you took time some
people go cold turkey they're just like
done not going to do it some people go
very much over a period of years of
slowly eliminating things going from no
red meat to vegetarian - vegan so so
then what were those other ones for you
you knew he said took off yogurt took
off milk and then definitely cheese was
the hardest and at that time there
weren't any vegan cheese's I recently
went to okay so my business partner
Michelle was adopted and found her
biological father by a DNA testing and
now he's been welcomed into our lives
and we hang out with him and he became
vegan because she's Ian so it was really
cool and we recently were in LA and we
went to a pizza place and the pizza
place had vegan cheese but no vegan
meats and he's a new vegan and he I
remember him he went up there and he was
like what kind of pizza place doesn't
have vegan meats and I was like oh my
gosh we're so spoiled and you don't even
know it because vegan cheese is the new
like a new phenomenon right now I
remember just mmm five years ago
three years ago there were not nearly as
many good and none of them melted and
now we're so fortunate where we have
some options that melt so you can eat
eat that and feel like you're eating
pizza yeah yeah so cheese was the
hardest for me cheese was really
difficult and it was something I would
say okay I'm done eating cheese oh yeah
I'm not done eating cheese and so yeah
that was the hardest for me and then you
were also giving us this really awesome
timeline of how over time we've had
products that have come onto the market
like vegan cheese and vegan meats and
we are a huge fan of when these these
these additional products come into the
market that are able to kind of unlock
people's access to vegetarian or vegan
plant-based diets because then they say
oh I can still have cheese that melts on
my pizza but it's vegan cheese yeah it
usually it's made out of like cashews is
that right it's like cashew cheese or
like well there are lots of cheese now
Jesus now one of my favorites is cashew
base that's me Lucas cheese okay and
then there's daya
that's a pea protein pea protein
yep and daya is super accessible and you
can find it up I believe for Walmart and
I believe Target so yeah accessibility
yeah so no okay but then how did it end
up getting to the first book that you
ended up authoring yeah okay so then
somewhere in there I started working for
a farmed animal sanctuary and around
that time my life kind of just fully
became vegan advocacy I wanted to teach
people about plant-based living vegan
food vegan lifestyle the whole works
and something that I heard over and over
and over and over again is that being
vegan is too expensive and and I even
heard it from my own family who I really
wanted to eat healthier I didn't I mean
I wanted them to eat plant-based I told
them hey I'm thriving on a plant-based
diet but I really just wanted them to be
hopeful and they were suffering some
severe consequences of die related the
poor diet choices including heart
attacks my uncle's 40 when he had his
first heart attack
or when he had a heart attack my grandpa
had passed away already from
complications in a triple bypass surgery
and he had already had one heart attack
I had type 2 diabetes and then passed
away after having multiple amputations
and so type 2 diabetes Clint her life
and these are things that could have
been avoided had either they received
the proper education on
where the doctor said and I don't know
what this happened but the doctor said
hey a lifestyle change needs to happen
immediately because your life is at risk
and and so I I was very young when all
this happened I don't know
if they received that education but I
imagine if their life was on a line they
would have chosen life and and so I
created plant based on a budget with
some friends to show people that eating
plant-based could be done very
affordably and conveniently you didn't
have to go to shop at all these
expensive grocery stores you didn't have
to go to your local co-op you could go
to any grocery store and eat a healthy
plant-based diet and we did that by
sharing recipes that our families liked
and that was helpful for my family and
from there it just grew it I created
different resources that had asked my
audience what they wanted and over time
created which is now my full-time job
plan based on a budget and then
somewhere in there someone reached out
to me and asked if I wanted to write a
cookbook which was my first cookbook
that was the super easy begin slow
cooker cookbook I didn't know a lot
about slow cookers but I did know that
my audience would appreciate something
that only had a 15 minute active prep
time so all of the recipes you would
just chop everything up within 15
minutes dump it in the slow cooker and
then you could either go to sleep and
wake up and have food or go to work and
come home and have food and I know that
my audience is tired from work they are
busy they're on a budget they don't want
to spend a lot of money they don't want
to spend a lot of time and that concept
would be very beneficial to them so
that's why I wrote that book 15 minutes
of chopping prep time prep time yep and
then you did put it all new that's
getting this stuff out of the
refrigerator that's opening up a can of
beans 15 minutes for it all dump it and
then you have a meal when you're done
from work yeah
whoa and this is normally it's some sort
of
and veggie type some some grain is that
usually what it is there were over 100
recipes in that book so there's a wide
variety of recipes and a lot of them I
ended up tailoring for this book well I
would say probably like 10 recipes I put
in this book for the stovetop
so I altered them based on some feedback
that I got from my first book and
improved them and showed people how they
could do it in the pressure cooker the
slow cooker and on the stovetop because
not everyone has it so kosher and not
everyone has an instant pot so the stove
is a it's a tried and true way to get
food cooked for you and you kept a
similar theme well I really want to see
you know your audience you have this
really strong it's really um this
tendency to want to like talk to your
audience like oh yeah yeah so do you
would you get like feedback and like
what was the receptivity that you were
getting from the first book and how you
ended up wandering yourself into the
second one well the first one I it did
really well so it's been out since 2017
and I have sold about 55,000 copies so
that's a lot of books bad a thousand
copies and so that one did really well
but what I wanted I want to serve my
audience I do this work because I feel
it's beneficial to the people who put
their faith in me to help them navigate
plant-based eating and I wanted to
create this ultimate resource for them
that's easy that will help their family
save money that will teach them the
basics but also have something for the
experienced cook who is looking for
something different and that's why I
created plant-based on a budget I poured
my heart and soul it is everything that
I've ever thought in my head should be
in a cookbook yes in a cookbook and I
worked on it for about two years before
it came out yesterday and
I'm really proud of it some things that
I included in the book are a picture
with every recipe I know that I am very
visual so I don't want to flip through a
cookbook and see a bunch of text I want
to see beautiful colorful photos that
inspire me to make it and then something
else I'll show it to you really quickly
yes I included these tips because I want
people to customize my recipe is based
on their family's preferences and so I
put the recipe the ingredients and then
I put some optional additions say you
have these or you have enough some extra
money you can put some optional
additions and then I put some tips for
either making the recipe in a variation
or you can also it's like a tip to make
it an easier process and then I had my
testers do tips and then I put space for
them to write their own touches and that
they could have a log of that exactly
because I know when I first started
learning to cook I wrote all over my
books and that's how I that's how I
learned that a cook is it gonna go there
it is yeah
yeah I I also realized that when I was
when I was looking and I was seeing that
that there's a there's a this is it's
because it fits within a certain amount
of about $1 to $2 a meal which is crazy
about like 20 to 35 dollars a week and
produce costs and then then you get the
optional editions so for those that have
some extra funds that they can add those
super-easy direction and ingredient
lists and these are all under 30 minutes
of time then you have your tips other
testers tips so this is again an
audience which is attributing which is
really cool because a lot of the people
were people from all over the country so
I had 40 recipe testers and they varied
from very young one of them was in
elementary school and to people who were
older
people who had never cooked people who
were experienced chefs vegans non vegans
people who just all across it they lived
in rural towns urban towns and I love
that diversity because that's who's
reading the book you just never knowed
was picking up the book or their cooking
skill level or where they live the
access to grocery stores and I wanted
everyone regardless of where they are
who they are old they are to be able to
cook these recipes easily and that's
super evident effort I just love how you
said that it's everything that you had
formed in your mind over the last even
like not just two years but throughout
learning of your process like decade
more and that then you were able to put
it into something that you said that's
so accessible for all different types of
people and so this is not only is it
that it's accessible like financially
it's also accessible in terms of the you
don't need the co-op's and yeah you can
you can shop at a Walmart or Target near
in your local rural area and
accessibility in price twenty to thirty
five dollars a week one to two dollars a
meal but also that the sections in here
are very interesting you have one pot
meals basics apps salads dinners
desserts and a sample meal plan I would
love for you to teach us about those
sections well I
okay so I started meal planning I offer
meal plans on plant-based meal plan calm
and I learned what people wanted I
created these meal plans that showed
people how to save money and often that
is not including desserts that's not
including a savory snack and people
really wanted those things so I knew I
needed to include desserts because
people have a sweet I have a sweet tooth
I don't I don't want to feel like
plant-based eating is taking away
something from my life I want it to be
helping me and only bringing me goodness
not taking away the goodness so I
definitely have the real-deal chocolate
chip
jeez I have chocolate pie in there and
those are always crowd-pleasers so these
are very limited the ingredient list
it's also there's a tiny ingredient and
the ingredient lists that are vegan oh
he came yeah and and then something I
knew I wanted to include was the one pot
meals because I hate doing dishes I do
not want to do dishes ever sometimes do
have these recipes that require like
first a little pot then the big pot then
bake it then do this and then stir it in
this bowl and I did not want to have my
my audience doing dishes for 45 minutes
after they cooked for the 30 minutes and
so I created the one pot meals that are
all easily adapted to be instant pot
meals too so you can just chop
everything and throw them either on the
stovetop or in the instant pot and I
give you directions for both in that way
at the end you only have your one pot to
clean yeah you even you even have a an
example on yeah right here
the bed the veggie the veggie chow mein
right that's one of the one pots yeah
yeah so Ron can you see that one
I yeah it's on okay yeah and you can you
can see how this is all done in one the
celery the carrots this the soy sauce is
all done in one yeah you know yep in the
noodles and so it's great to be able to
do they literally one dish afterward
plus like your fork and you're like
spoon that you used to mix it up exactly
yeah
that's so awesome and so what I love to
do with this because I only feed to
people is that I make leftovers so that
I don't have to make lunch or worry
about lunch the next day and so
sometimes we can feed the two of us for
dinner than the two of us for lunch the
next day and then maybe one other day
that week with the batch of food that I
made so that it's really limiting my
time in the kitchen I I love food and I
think that people often think wow Tony's
such a foodie she loves all things food
but I love eating food I don't want to
spend all my time in the kitchen I want
to spend my time hanging out in the
fence and a family going on a walk and
not doing dishes and standing and less
stirring and it's it's kind of my means
to an end I want to eat and enjoy that
delicious homemade food yeah you
short-short cook time limited amount of
dishes afterwards huge and then I want
you to teach people most people I don't
think know that you can even like make
cookies with a vegan can you explain
instead of like eggs and butter like
what are you using yes so there are in
my cookies I use applesauce and that
would be in place of an egg hmm and then
I also use vegan butter which is you can
find out any grocery store that you can
often find either margarine or vegan
butter like Earth Balance and Earth
Balance a tub of it I bought it from a
store where I live called Winco it's
like a big warehouse grocery store and
it was three dollars and thirty cents so
it is not expensive and you can even
find the
blocks of margarine for like $2 yeah so
it's not an additional it's not like
your cookies are now going to be double
the cost yeah because you chose you
chose the plant-based version and then
the chocolate chips I use semi-sweet
chocolate chips the cheapest that I
found are at Trader Joe's or dollar 98
for a bag of semi-sweet chocolate chips
and those are non-dairy and super
delicious nice nice so these are these
are those those tricks that applesauce
instead of an egg like that
that's correct like what yeah and okay
so that was some of the one pot basics
especially for not doing the mountains
of dishes and then the hacks for some of
the desserts and then you all you said
that you some of this I mean some of the
salads in here were like that's what's
up I love that I love that the styles of
salads and then this the meal plan as
well teach us about the other sections
as well okay so what I'm most known for
on the internet my work that is the most
popular is the meal plans that I
co-created with my friend Michelle came
my friend she runs a website called
world of vegan and we created these meal
plans called the plant based on a budget
meal plans it teaches people how to eat
for $25 a week that's 120 a meal we do
breakfast lunch and dinner seven days
and provide a grocery shopping list
broken down by where you are in the
store it has a colorful photo with every
single recipe and they became really
popular so that I knew that when I won
when I created my book I wanted to
include that because people have a hard
time piecing together what they're gonna
eat in a week so that's why I included
in my book and so then you're sending
people to a grocery store one time a
week and from that this is the business
partner yep right here yeah okay
and then you're sending them once so
you're sending them one time a week and
then they're getting the meals for all
seven days in one shrimp and so some of
them may be like like sweet potatoes
that they get for the meal on Monday
we'll also you'll use sweet potatoes
again on Saturday you'll use 100% of the
ingredients that you purchased and I
show you how to divvy it up so say you
have that sweet potato I'll show you
we're gonna use we'll buy two sweet
potatoes we're gonna use 1/3 of the
sweet potatoes this way and then the
rest of it will be this way and that is
to help people understand that they
don't need to be stocking their
refrigerator with things that may expire
you know I know that I personally have
had the experience where I have the best
intentions I'd go buy cilantro and
parsley fresh parsley and lettuce and
kale and then I don't get to it and I
have to throw it away
and so forth so we're trying to teach
people how to buy only what you need go
to the bulk bins buy only what you need
and I tell people go to the bulk bins
with your measuring cups put the bag
around it so that you're not
contaminating all the bulk items but
you're only measuring what you need so
if you're making a recipe that calls for
one cup of brown rice only buy one cup
of brown rice you don't need to buy a 2
pound bag of brown rice because then
you're spending extra money you're
probably not going to eat that brown
rice anytime soon and this way you're
only buying what you need yep yep and
you get into a rhythm of going once a
week getting what you need for the seven
days not throwing away the excess food
that's so critical and that's
time-saving too because I know that for
myself when I'm not meal planning I will
be more impulsive about my cooking I'll
be like mmm I want to eat this but I
only have one of the things I need to
make it so that I'm gonna do a grocery
store and then two days later same thing
I'm gonna go to the grocery store again
I'm spending time I don't really have at
the grocery store multiple times a week
instead of being
efficient and using my time wisely going
only once and being organized when I'm
at the grocery store so I try to
encourage people not to be so impulsive
about their food shopping but rather be
organized and go and shop with intention
it's so cool being able to repurpose
things from one grocery trip at the
beginning of the week to be able to
repurpose them throughout the week yep
so that especially so that they don't
get wasted and yet the impulsivity
decreases sometimes we walk through and
we're hungry and then we just take a
bunch of stuff because I was very very
hungry yeah and okay this another
another aspect to this is that you gave
us the example of chocolate chip cookies
there's a mango smoothie Bowl there's
another one of the assets we have
sunflower seed pesto teriyaki stir-fry
we'll show it a little bit earlier but
just kind of like the general idea is
that it's all across and there's so many
different options there's hundred plus
options in here and then on the on the
both on on so on your social media
platforms your first of all I mean your
your just your your career crushing it
like you hear you're crushing it your
plan based on a budget
Instagram account has 200,000 plus
followers also the in the the content on
here is like you know obviously it's
gorgeous content and then you have a
little blurb at the bottom for every
single one of the posts yeah so what I
do on there is I have a variety I found
that okay this is sound sounds really
crazy but I found that the uglier the
photo the more it the better it performs
no I know it boy no I I feel the same
way but what I found that does really
well like you just click on this photo
yeah that is a phone photo photo yeah
that has 5,000 like yeah
hundreds of comments but people want to
know what I'm eating when I'm eating it
and so they I find that regime if I say
okay so hey guys today I threw in some
onions and bell pepper some brown rice
and some quinoa and some black beans
into the instant pot with some broth and
made a soup now it gives them a little
bit of an idea of what they can go home
and do it's something that I I took with
the photo so that I'm sorry with my
phone so they can see that it's not
super style they can envision themselves
eating that meal and and sometimes I
think it's a little bit harder so like
you can see and in this photo right here
that's in my pot on my stove yep and you
can go home you can be like oh I could
do that and you can envision yourself
making that at your house instead of
something that's super stylized and with
lighting and props and and it just is
more realistic now realistic that's
that's quite interesting some more
realistic images that people can
actually do at home will end up getting
more yet interest ah I I do both though
I have a variety I've got some staged
photos and then some photos like that
which is just what I ate at home yet yep
and and those always do better Ron how
hungry are you right now oh my gosh oh
the main embargo so really good yeah
yeah that sounds so good YUM so another
thing is that you have these jokes like
you have this dine at this dinosaur once
this funny yeah yeah I like to invited
their herbivore I like to make it fun I
want to have people not be so uptight
about it
and you know sometimes people I know
that for example one of my friends the
only time ago she was every time we ate
plant-based food she would be like ah
why like I'm crazy my body's crazy meat
and it say you have these friends here
maybe a little bit skeptical about your
diet or don't want to only plant-based
food with you and so I just that's funny
it is exactly getting people on your
side that way I also want to I also want
to plug the the YouTube channel your
YouTube channel is has a lot of really
strong you know that was the video we
showed on the veggie chow mein but
they're super short like a minute long
video and it's really well produced and
so it's it can be replicated at home
quite easily and there's so many options
thank you
yeah Hasselback potatoes cinnamon rolls
tasty tofu tacos breaded tofu strips
recipe yep easy edamame salad so this is
also tony Okimoto on youtube as well
yep yep and i do a variety of videos i
michelle who I work with I worked with
on B no plans she is a video producer
too and so I on her channel a lot of
these you'll see a lot of us yes we have
those they're longer videos that teach
people exactly what okay so we'll say
there are 20 yogurts that are non-dairy
on the market right now which are good
you know that you're not spending your
money trying food that you may not like
because it's the worst of all of the
options available so we'll do a taste
test to screen and offer our opinions
for whatever they're worth and help
guide people into what is the better
better options so that they can try
maybe the top 3 instead of trying 10
that are not that good save people time
money with it and you'll probably
actually keep more people coming because
of that whereas if they had a bad
experience they might just drop it right
away
and some of them do really well like
this one is nearly a hundred thousand
years it's been at for a year and it's
um
Trader Joe's Hall it's just let's begin
a Trader Joe's was awesome what is
unexpected or there are some things that
are are expected that are plant-based
but I I know that we each pick ten
things and I had never tried some of the
things that she had chosen because I
have you know when you have your things
that you like and just being introduced
to new plant-based options at a place
that you regularly shop it's fun yeah
yeah this is great you can go with a
partner and say okay go get your ten
favorite vegan foods and then you'll get
your ten and then you'll probably have
like a couple at least that are not
overlapping which then you can learn
about why they pick those couple yeah
that's a great it's actually a good way
to to go and start sharing experiences
and build community that way a hundred I
was a hundred thousand views on video
awesome stuff awesome stuff there's so
much content um it's great that you're
doing this because you like you have you
have to have the media side of this
knocked and you do you have the
Instagram rolling and and the YouTube
rolling and have you all like have you
already been getting feedback on some of
the contents only been a day but yeah
one of you what have you been hearing
about like seven hundred and eightieth
in the total Amazon book rankings yeah
that's like eight million books in your
780 why very honored it's been a really
amazing past 24 hours since my book came
out and I I'm really grateful for the
response so far I know that for sure we
had over a thousand pre-sales pre
pre-ordered books on Amazon and I've
been hearing from people talking about
how they founded that Costco I founded a
Whole Foods and so there it is number
seven 21 in books
Ron if you zoom out a little bit I have
it zoomed in number seven 21 in books
number two in budget cooking number
three in Whole Foods diets
number six in vegan cooking books good
day it's a good I feel like life is
absence Lewis its ups and downs and I'm
so on like I'm still happy to be at it
up right now yeah it's hard work two
years of hard work you said that for all
the photographs that it took you way way
Tony you have to tell this story you
spent you spent five straight days
making a hundred of the meals for the
photographs yep so I had worked with my
friend Jenny before she was recommended
to me and then we became friends she's a
photographer here in San Francisco and I
knew I wanted to work with her again so
I called her up I said hey I'm writing
this book can you come and at the time
she was living in Denver can you come
and make a hundred recipes with me and
photograph them and and do it in one
sitting so oh we did it we cooked 100
recipes and or up all day all night
doing it and my house was like one it
was comical because I had 100 recipes
worth of food and I had as many people
as I could come with her Tupperware I
said if you live within 10 miles of me
come eat food at my house bring your
Tupperware I will feed you all week
bring it and and then I was just bunny
to watch us go I played the whole Taylor
Swift discography we both were Taylor so
we had just seen her in concert and so
Taylor Swift fueled this musically
musically yep
so it was a really fun time and it was a
lot of work and I'm so grateful to her
and then I have some lifestyle photos
which are really great lifestyle is the
ones if I'm in there in the photo like
the back of the book
Michelle came she is a photographer too
she did those and then you love avocados
so much there's the there's the
lifestyle photo that's you with some
salad in the park in Sacramento yes and
then it's not on the program feed that's
great so then there's also like okay
hold on I wanna I want to see if I can
if I can snag it oh I found another good
lifestyle photo and this one right here
well that's my brother this is you and
your brother yeah
and those are the orange creamsicles yep
frozen bananas plant-based milk orange
juice and vanilla extract and that one
is the one that the little boy Tyler
tostado
he is in elementary school and he was
one of my recipe jesters for that recipe
so it was so cute he did a little
YouTube video as his critique so he
showed himself making it and then he
gave me his thoughts on the recipe when
it was done I'm just really really cute
this is great to be able to engage young
people in it as well yeah there are a
couple recipes which I recommend and
look for making with your kids oh cool
which which ones do off the bat
definitely that creamsicle recipe but
there's also this one that is there a
boat meal peanut butter raisin balls and
so it's fun to to make them into little
balls and then you refrigerate them and
yeah I would have loved I mean I love
doing it now so I can only imagine that
a child would enjoy that experience yes
almond butter raisin balls YUM yes and
you can you can customize it you can
use cranberries instead of raisins you
can put in some sunflower seeds extra
protein maybe some banana if you want
definitely customize this some coconut
shreds coconut shreds are awesome I'm
gonna switch it up to almond butter if
you want you know there's all different
kinds of you know when I went when first
when we were talking I was like yeah
overnight oats like put the almond milk
and in the oats and let it soak
overnight there's the you know those
very just couple ingredient smoothies
that are so good the the veggie chiles
have been very popular there's just so
many awesome recipes in here that I hope
that when when when when we think about
it on a whole this is maybe the question
that I should ask you then what what are
your thoughts then are we kind of talked
about a little bit with some of the
advances that are being made and clean
me some of the you know fifty years from
now will be like what were you doing
slaughtering so many of the animals so
what are your what are your thoughts on
the direction on the future of food well
I'm pleased I have been doing a
newsletter on the plant based on a
budget newsletter that I put out on
Fridays that gets people excited about
what's happening in the plant-based base
and these past few weeks have just been
amazing we've had beyond me go public
and do really well we've had impossible
being served at places like Burger King
yep I went and tried the del Taco beyond
crumbles I've had the Beyond burger at
Carl's jr. and it's just amazing to me
that if you're on a road trip or if
you're late and you just or if you come
home and you don't want to cook dinner
you have these options available to you
and I don't think that if you're on a
budget you should be eating those
options all the time because they're
more expensive for sure going to fast
food even if you eat animal products
it's definitely more expensive than
eating at home cooking for yourself and
meal planning but to have those options
available it's just it's
the game changing it makes it you know
some so much more accessible and it also
introduces people to to that style of
food plant-based food I know that I have
a lot of friends who are curious and
they eat there anyway and so while
they're there
they'll try maybe one beef taco one
beyond taco and that's really cool that
it's exposing new people to the
plant-based options yes kind of coming
in like right in time with some of the
issues around human cost climate change
and coming in right in time hopefully
yes I'm watching Paul and I are watching
the our planet series have you seen it
it's I think so Daily Planet series yeah
it's on Netflix yeah and it's the star
damage it's gorgeous
yes but afterward every time I'm like oh
we're killing the animal like art the
our impact on the planet is so negative
that it's affecting all of even like the
algae on the ice which then feeds the
fish which feeds the Penguins which
feeds the whale or you know isn't the
sea lion yeah so it's just yeah I heard
they're gonna cancel funding for planet
Earth did you hear that did our planet
uh yeah cancel funding competitor yeah
don't give them any more money our
planet was made by the same people as
Planet Earth was yeah yeah okay okay
cool yeah cuz when I saw the the trailer
said I was like this is gorgeous
yes yes this is a way to yeah connect
deeper to the to the beautiful place we
call home
okay let's do we covered I think pretty
much everything yeah pretty much at
least as well as we could in the short
time we had together can't believe that
it's yeah under 30 dollars a week in
less than 30 minutes a meal let
do a couple quick simulation questions
on the way out of the show that we like
asking our guests all right let's do it
all right first question is are we alone
in the cosmos that is an interesting
question
I feel like Paul will be really good at
this because he is all about space he is
the biggest space nerd I've ever met
actually his wedding ring is meteorite
but I I don't know I would say based on
what I hear from Paul I would say no and
then what about are we in a simulation
you're asking me the tough questions
today I don't know what do you think
what is wrong think what is fun thing
well we are in a simulation it is a game
of sorts however we are still in charge
and we are the authors it's very complex
it's very yeah good yes we're
discovering this as we advance our own
technology
we're with we're seeing what we're made
of we are of virtual reality this is
that's good yeah yeah see this is a
first successful redirect Tony goes what
do you think I'm like what do you think
Ron again it's only what we think it's
what we believe our reality is based on
you know what we believe so it's uh it's
destiny yeah that was a solid answer on
it that's good yeah
yeah play the game Tony's leveled up her
her experience points and plant-based
nutrition are maxed out her plant-based
bars maxed out I love it
and then how about we ask last question
which is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world compassion
compassion is the most beautiful thing
in the world to treat people with
fairness and dignity and respect and to
do things that are beneficial to others
in the planet without any personal gain
that is that is very beautiful whoa that
was really strong yeah yeah compassion
plus the eagle less contributions to
civilization yeah yeah Tony this is the
such a fun episode thank you so much for
coming on the show really appreciate it
and congrats
holy cow like seven hundred twenty on
the book list like in the top couple in
the cooking and plant category base
categories already on Amazon everyone I
would love for you to check out the
links below check out the book
plant-based on a budget the links below
also check out playing bass on budget
calm plant-based meal plan calm and as
well as go follow the Instagram and
YouTube accounts for Tony and for
plant-based let's have more
conversations with our friends our
families or coworkers online on social
media about what this all means about
being able to save money prep our meals
and cook our meals in very small short
amount of time and be able to live
healthier more sustainably on this
planet together so go and talk more
about it also give us your thoughts in
the comments below in the episode also
huge shout out to round Boggess for
producing and directing thank you very
much and support the artists
entrepreneurs and the organizations
around the world that you believe in
support simulation our links are below
help us continue growing and scaling our
impact go and build the future everyone
manifest your dream since the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will
you soon
[Music]